peut-on envoyer ce sujet s'il vous plaît
en régie merci de votre réponse la régie
bon et bien une petite difficulté donc
je vous disais il ya quelques instants
voilà un petit problème avec notre un
petit problème avec notre reportage eh
bien nous n'y arrivons pas décidément
nous allons féliciter l'équipe technique
l'électricité a été coupée dans
l'immeuble de l'avenue montaigne nous
nous sommes mis sur groupe électrogène
maintenant nous sommes revenus sur le
secteur bien je suppose je suppose que
nous allons continuer la suite de ce
journal ne parlait pas trop fort dans
l'oreille s'il vous plaît on va parler
dans ce journal de la guerre iran irak
bien de la guerre dans le golfe paraît
pardon de la rentrée scolaire et des
événements diplomatiques de ce week-end
notamment la rencontre bush gorbatchev
je crois maintenant que le les magnétos
sont réparés nous avons de sérieuses
difficultés techniques il faut
d'ailleurs dire et vous nous en excuser
que ça fait plusieurs jours que ça dure